ok pessoal eu tenho aqui o balão
conhecido por ser instrutivo é o preço
2o um ano vocês nem sabem que continue o
play
meu deus só tem uma pasta uma pasta uma
pasta é bom vocês nunca entendi as
piadas nunca nunca uma página basta ver
o pessoal aqui quem fala andar que sejam
muito bem vindos
arranjam bagão mas eles postaram o vídeo
eu vou avançar porque tô com foco é um
só esta partida muito boa série foi
consistente com o melhor experimentar um
livro e um ministro é o cheiro já me
sinto assim de forma de ensinar a minha
parte olha aí é só por água
agora é só pra isso aqui era muito pouco
tempo fazer então é bom e agora está
aqui e não quero eu lembro quem é e não
só o que gostam de fazer hoje
hoje o vídeo teve com balões que o que
não pode faltar aqui neste canal nem
destruição é é a destruição do balão e
pipoca vou deixar a faca e vou deixar
sofrendo uma guarda da qual é a coisa
mais sensível do mundo é que um objeto
que quando vocês tocam aqui dos
problemas que enfrenta logo pois claro
só claro uma lomba e praticamente coisa
mais frágil num play meta logo é muito
sensível que vocês já sabem pessoal é
que o seguinte ó que andar que vai dar a
volta à situação é eu vou tornar o balão
é coisa mais resistentes do mundo diz
planeta
neste universo nesta galáxia nesta folha
da galáxia da china é porque cheguei
mais longe do universo
não sei que todos irmos para lá então
construir aqui pessoal o balão mais
resistente do mundo ea nós construímos
aqui o nosso nome pessoal quero pedir
uma coisa muito importante é eu quero ir
muito longe que neste vídeo quando mesmo
com o vosso por aqui no espírito e por
que por que autorizar um calção médio
fashion paraíba o sol não vai sair só
com o mesmo com você é que neste vídeo
isso ajuda muito é que o canal e vocês
não foram inscritos em inscrevam se
carregue no cine preferem todos os vi
falar estou construindo que o nosso
bolão e como fazer o primeiro passo pra
saber da existência do balão uma lance
normal
eu estou ok nada porque aí eu vou testar
agora foi casa
o dado é fogo é cunha opzz mata mosca
martelo mas como vocês podem ver o
pessoal o balão não exista nada nada
nada com muita coisa que vem do balão é
muito sensível a qualquer solo vamos
mostrar aqui um dos truques que o
prendia tem na escola quando deixar o
balão resistente ao fogo olha só achei
que o balão com água e agora vou encher
o recinto com a 15 e 19 e neste preciso
ponto que nós vamos usar nossos quero
que vocês vão ver o que vai acontecer lá
a321 vai
espero que o uso do balão então pelo
menos contra o fogão já tenha uma
solução que só tinha um balão de água
mas falta tudo o resto material a
faculdade de fato muita coisa ainda
então um por um e vou ter que descobrir
a solução para este balão não rebentar
com vocês já puderam vir água dentro do
látex tem muito mais força então vão
encher o balão tudo com a água que bebe
sua volta e vejam só jackman não sei com
água
o próximo passo adiante você vê aqui é
agora é tornar o látex mais resistentes
e com linguagem fazer isso pessoal do
prefeito eu respeito isso é pessoal é
isso que vocês vão pensar eu vou furar
completamente o balão conseguiu bater pé
pelo menos até que vai dar uma camada
muito mais resistente o balão e eu até
duvido que este dardak consiga entrar no
balão que o dado é muito afiado mas se
rolar muito bom esse tempo eu acho que
nem chegar contrato então vamos lá
tentar fazer isso só se vocês acham que
vai dar certo quem tem bom e creche foi
dar errado comenta aí mata música é
esquece vai dar certo comenta balão que
acha que vai dar errado comenta massa
música embora lá ver quem vai ganhar eu
porque eu acho que vai ser um balão eu
acho que o curso que fazer com que o
volume existem já está pronta aqui e
agora é só arrumar
eu acho que é só isso eu vou tentar
fazer uma camada muito grossa e eu não
posso apertar muito porque eu ficar
assim muito congresso eu basicamente
assistentes então eu não quero isso acho
que é muito boa mas acabaria sul
a sorte não parece um balão está
parecido com uma embalagem uma encomenda
ok pessoal é que o nosso super tepco
olha aí já está no fim então já não há
mais mas ainda tenho outro rumo mas
vamos deixar isso para uma segunda
camada que há nem parece um bolão está
muito pesado o que absorve o próximo
passo agora é tornar mais resistente
porque eu acho que mesmo seus para faca
eu vou argumentar ou até mesmo dado o
martelo o próprio mata moscas não acho
que nossa música e assistir ã o balão
por tio mata música que na ponta é isso
meu deus há muito resistentes falar e se
conectar esses 30 o fogo então vamos
tentar fazer alguma coisa é que fogo é
isso que vou fazer e como é que eu vou
fazer isso ao vejam só aí foi só comprei
essa papel de alumínio porque eu vou
usar isso como você está bem esse papel
domínio não queima eu só que esse mas
não caiba tipo não pega fogo então eu
vou furar tudo nosso bolão com esse
domínio eu acho para ser sua lógica vai
ficar muito resistente
o pessoal cerro é muito que você se
conectar a uma bola gigante do alumínio
ok agora tá assistindo ao fogo eu acho
eu vou tentar os arquivos quer 321 vai o
ficou preto e com muito preto e agora
passou a precificar nenhum demais
assistindo eu vou colar estudo com mais
não vai provocar muito mais agora eu
acho que você vai ficar resistente à
queda porque nós não estaremos também só
lucas se inscrever quem é que você vai
ganhar seu pessoal está comentário
falamos eu só tô aqui pra matar música
ok eu não vou gastar sobretudo porque eu
ainda preciso fazer um do espaço então
vamos contar um pouco sobre até porque
vai ser usada esquerdo ao cair vou
tentar atirar ao chão assim banho leve
só para o estado
embora o a321 vai mesmo assim eu quero
tentar uma queda maior portanto vamos
reforçar ainda mais o balão e o que eu
comprei pessoal mas não só aí comprei
ele é aquela coisa para pôr na mesa é
porque se um prato típico nos colegas
sabem além de sua raça estão na escola é
um cachecol tony que eu tô aí meu deus o
flash e como vocês podem ver ela é bem
fofo então eu acho que vai se sair muito
bem a queda eu vou arrumar aqui sim tudo
agora vamos fazer outra camada por cima
sim porque comprei mais olha aí olha sou
e ser muito grande aí já nem dá pra ver
o subtrai pole isso e não vamos deixar
outra camada por cima ok agora isso vou
colocar assim só pra ficar assimétrico
agora é só aprender tudo muito bem e eu
só postar uma camada extra de segurança
pessoal agora é só construir os nossos
balões e usarem na nossa festa de
aniversário
imaginem só muito desse valor de pi
aparelho mas o pessoal só assim ó o fim
do que é isso mas é um balão
olhei e se balançar a saída da aula e
destrutiva olha acabou suau meu deus já
não têm mais por acaso já não tem mesmo
mais sensual agora sim nós conseguimos
construir o nosso rolar um instrutivo
olha isso está muito grande
além da prova d'água essa água está
quase na china aceita muito bem
só vou tirar agora a bola no chão e
vamos ver o que vai acontecer 32 não
aconteceu e eu vou tentar mais alto
ainda para 32 sul vai vai
o balão que só vou começar pelo motel
para provar e comer bem mais pessoal
cometem mais balão o mata mosca comida e
32 ainda está vivo
estou muito feliz estou muito feliz por
voltar até agora é hora é agora
pessoal vamos estar aqui um novo dado
agora seu argumentário cérebro coleções
ser muito fiado ok vou deixar o balão e
vamos fazer o teste mas já sabem pessoal
e como fazer a equipe reagir portanto
não façam isso em casa o pessoal já sabe
mais uns vídeos apenas divirtam-se mas
não se tem em casa por vocês podem se
magoado e eu não quero isso não então é
estar aqui obesidade pessoal embora lá
estava eu acho que o furacão
toda hora vejo mais o luxo do espírito
não é o ok agora supostamente ter suas
primeiras aqui e ver se sai água se não
sair agora porque existiu até agora
ainda só resistiu à voz da dubai a
escutou três agora fui eu acho que o
volume movimentado no ainda está cheio
de propriedade dos índios onde sul é
falar está qualquer coisa lá dentro que
não deixaram ele entrar bahuan encontra
faca para lá em 321 vai
o que não posso só entrou num centro de
ponta embora 321 vai isso não passa mais
no sentindo só eu acho que o papel do
ministro tempo quer voltar com mais
força agora para lá 321 vai agora foi
agora foi agora entrou muito
agora entro muito meu deus não não é
feito com uma simples obra não só o
outro aponta todas as mãos o corte que
fez voltar a funcionar
só vou tentar mais uma vez que eu vou
tentar com muita força a bola lá 32 vai
agora foi fã agora foi não é impossível
não ter argumentado que tem metade da
faca
os mapas e músicas ganharam esta
competição eu acho que ainda vamos ver o
pessoal da equipe mata-moscas ganhou a
desculpa que estava comigo nós
conseguimos furar o balão mas que isso
pode se tornar uma série tal como seria
do cofre e todos sabem o software em que
o torna um balão ainda mais resistente
sei lá eu até posso ficar bom com
plástico com ferro como a 0 contudo que
não cometem se quiserem ver uma série de
vídeos é tentar deixar este balão
indiscutível e só deixei muito aqui no
espírito sério e sisudo muito que o
canal porém nós aqui no canal também
inscrevam se ativem o sininho e só
espero que tenham gostado fiquem bem a
próxima hora